just because you hang out with someone
every day doesn't mean it's the best
friendship in the world
yeah I can take the easy example
co-workers of course you spend a lot of
time with them every day because you
have to write if you're if you're
working at the cubicle next to someone
you're probably gonna spend a lot of
time with and hopefully you can build a
good acquaintance ship with them and and
you're good acquaintances you get along
really well and you have a nice working
dynamic but just because you're around
someone doesn't that doesn't mean
they're your friend and the opposite is
also true I think some of my closest
relationships one of my closest primary
and secondary relationships are people I
see once or twice a year and I mean even
people like my brother who have been
really reconnecting with it within the
last year we took different paths after
turning 18 and and well he's a year
older than me so he was 19 and it's like
whoever had some huge falling-out or
something we just drifted in different
directions and continued the drift and
drifted a little bit close from time to
time but now there were a certain stage
in our life or both in our late 30s
we've been able to sort of reflect back
and we're communicating a lot more and
so sometimes that distance creates the
path for you to reconnect in a way but
other times they're they're our friends
like my friend Adam in Tennessee who I
see him once or twice a year if I'm
lucky we might have a conversation once
a month or once every other month and
there are some of the most meaningful
conversations I have and part of that is
because of the distance if we were to
chat every single day it made we they
may not have the conversation may not
have the same weight but we can go away
and sort of like we basically he and I
do a podcast once a month without
recording it is the way that I look I'm
like this would be if we were recording
this would be the best podcast ever yeah
and the part of me like that makes it
even more precious because it's not
being recorded for posterity it's just
sort of out there in the ether and it's
gone and it makes this this beautiful
ephemeral experience and we can do that
once a month and come back and so one of
the things I want to just drive home is
you can have great relationships with
someone who's on the other side of the
country
other side of the world Derek Siver's
talked about this his five closest
friends three of them he has never met
in person
but he talks I'm on the phone all the
time yeah and so think about that as
well you can have unconventional
relationships and still have them be
rather meaningful absolutely
you